hey guys i'm ryan right hey i'm now if
there's one person I know that laughs up
[ __ ] time it is Selina Meyers so I
thought like I could probably been able
to pretty much complete the challenges
of these videos but I said no I don't
think chelina can so I'm challenging
because it literally is like this is a
challenge this was a challenge we're
going to try not to cry try not to laugh
and I also think trying to laugh or be
harder for her so try to laugh 2015
extremely hard Edition lets you okay
remember man I'm and part of the room
I'll know part of the rules of this game
is you can't smile or anything
Oh dad you know what but if you like
happen to crack you gotta get back into
it you know don't just quit just I'm not
a quitter
I'm not a quitter just are laughs right
winner okay do this it's always sad one
that's like the game is too easy because
the videos suck yeah
I'm serious I'm serious
Oh No are you know laughing I've seen
this before have you met oh okay
Oh father
yes my boy could you please make me some
food father anything for my boy drinks
sighs is that baby food ah are you mad
gonna let you slip you by you got next
how is closer Asia okay here's your good
cuz I want to know okay
so 150 kabillion people up and asking me
to uh do cinnamon challenge if you go to
my fan page on Facebook or any comments
from the last couple of videos I put up
and then you sing in the chapter and I
usually don't give in to peer pressure
because what's so challenging about
cinnamon really so uh everybody zoom in
on my nerves I guess I'm sitting me I
don't even know what kind of supposed to
get a little cinnamon is good for you
through put cinnamon on like you know
different drinks and stuff so um so you
take some sentiment or anything I guess
I don't
cyber spoon and I was a fool busyness I
would never find them cuz I don't know
how much you supposed to say so you just
take it and I guess you count to ten or
you take it in I don't know oh that's
alright so here's the cinnamon
alright alright here go
lighter better come laughter right I
know it hurt badly
that is the cinnamon challenge it
doesn't sound hard to do you do it and
it sucks my power I'm gonna pass on that
one
Oh God
[ __ ] hard I can relate
oh oh this is why you should never do
that alright that's it
uh I've seen several of these and none
of them agape like that okay that the
fart video I've never seen that one that
was [ __ ] hilarious how it is good I
think I guess because I've seen people
do the cinnamon challenge then I've done
it myself that's why I was able to like
really lack is like because she had no
idea what was going she was like this
isn't a big deal like and she seems so
genuine yeah and so I was like in my
head thinking she has no idea and then
what happened I was worse than I
expected cuz I didn't know she's gonna
take a big like now I just used to sweet
yeah Wow that was how I I greatly failed
that one yeah don't do things like that
that just doesn't seem like smart people
so I think there's better than to do
with your pocket do you send us other
challenges I know I want a real
challenge no no I completely failed not
just like I was ready for more send us
like you know try not to freak out try
not to I don't know try not to cry try
not to whatever just swore those I'm an
emotional person I like doing these
challenges makes a reaction seemed a
little worth it
you know anyway guys anyway guys anyway
guys anyway I'll try and make them
videos editing mistake if you're here to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Selina
Meyers channel fun [ __ ] on there and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter mainly to follow us on vine
because I'm having fun with that [ __ ]
because if we get enough followers we
can get product place
things such as USB keys USBs are great
you know they hold on to all your files
and if you have a girlfriend who likes
to go through your computer and look at
old photos of prior people you might
have [ __ ] and then you just so happen
to have pictures of them and maybe a
video or two that your ex doesn't even
know about you could put it on the USB
key brilliant and she'll never know but
you can still drag off to it thanks USB
key make me happy you met Evie thanks
Ryan key with pee pee